the Sun and the Earth
in each Cosmic exploration have a Divine
bond with all of the sentience that
secreted over the billions of years that
leads to the evolution of the Mind the
most complex symbolic abstract processor
that then undergoes the drama of the
creator with itself
it's just my metaphysics
you know I'm a alien by now so
are you
no a man with your ass
no it's very profound I was just curious
if that was a
something that you've studied or if
that's something that you
philosophize on or it's an assimilation
of a bunch of cosmic metaphysics and
direct experience across
when we were talking about galaxies
being decentralized Networks
that was awesome
I can feel that yeah
you feel that I was feeling that yeah I
was I just because you responded in a
different vibration yeah
yeah well I was able to go there
look at it feel it feel the waves coming
off of it and feel its pulse of its in
breath and out breath yes and
yes yes
it's true nice
fundamentally understands that it is
working together
and aware of
itself
yes
awesome to think that a Galaxy
itself can be aware of itself yes
look at it but it absolutely can which
is kind of like what that I was talking
about as well too 100 the entire
universe can do it but also a Galaxy can
do it in a human can do yeah
so there's all of these different
well the galaxy is the way that the
Creator expresses the combinatorics of
itself
and then furthermore the Mind Body
Spirit complexes of each Galaxy are
further combinatorial exploration and
expression of itself
what do you mean by combinatorial
because there's infinite combinations
there's infinite possibilities
girdle's incompleteness theorem is the
perfect way to describe the
the
impossibility of ever being able to come
to the end of all possibility
okay
when you just ask a kid will you ever
come to the end of infinity
a child will probably tell you no you
can't come to
come to finity
and then you ask well what kind of a
design would you make if you were
Infinity for you to be able to explore
endless potentiality then you would say
this is pretty good
not a bad
beautiful piece of art
if that were the title and then you saw
this yeah
great